I'm slightly shy and delighted to hear
all these beautiful words about me yes
it makes me feel good I have to say and
I hear them in the middle of Oscars and
I want to thank the four bright
beautiful and intelligent woman who
spoke and I have a little question are
they no man in this room who love me to
speak
boom in France when we want to watch the
Oscar ceremony we have to set up our
alarm clock at 4 a.m. and we want to see
the Fashion Show the room full of
excited people not to speak about the
anxious actors and artists because it's
a fierce competition what's happening
today has nothing to do it's another
kind there is no money at stake at stake
and no competition so the governor's
gave me this award
it just I took it as a recognition of my
body of work over the more than 60 years
and it how you see in light it gives
light on me as well as French cinema and
I'm happy that some of the leading
figures of France came to be with me and
enjoyed the even the evening so I want
to welcome them Fredrik brother is the
president of South Nationale du cinéma
that supports film and helps young
filmmakers then we have search to Vienna
with the president of pinnacle film
supporting films and helping young young
directors and sending the knowledge of
French cinema abroad and then we have
the delegation health of the can Film
Festival the famous serie primo
and I am also surrounded and protected
by my family I have a beautiful children
Mutsumi with actor and filmmaker Rosalie
verdad me who recently produced with
passion energy the film faces places
that I could directed with yeah J is
here with us and then share is on the
cake two of my grandchildren are here
Val intervene a with a DP and after
studying at AFI and my little yes and my
little constant enemy who's still at
school here in Los Angeles
how could I forget to name and speak
about Jack me my dear Jack who was here
in 1965 nominated for the umbrellas of
Cherbourg
[Applause]
back to the topic I've been and under
loved and praised I would say because I
try to work to get the essence of cinema
finding different structure for each
film Lapointe could double narration
kill you all from five to seven
real-time vagabond 13 continuous and and
continuous travelling shots
J&B each Patris is a puzzle with missing
pieces
so I also try to tell stories with
actors and non actors and went back to
the school of modesty which is
documentaries such as the Gleaners and I
but have to say I had a hard time
finding money I never met him never made
money and I'm not bankable
nevertheless if not money I got many
awards and then also corner area was
such as can pal model and later because
I became older and order without losing
my desire and desire and need to work
and create I started to get Lifetime
Achievement Awards but here in a mecca
of cinema Hollywood I received the best
one the governor governor's applaud
thank you and then have to say something
else you know the other day I woke up in
the middle of night the night thinking
about my speech I got nervous started to
move my legs and my arms in the bed
moving a lot and after a while for some
reason I start to forget the weight of
my body on the mattress I felt I was
dancing tonight
I have almost the same feeling it is a
big event very serious has been
organized to celebrate the honorees we
have a room here full of cinema talent
we had two stars Angelina and Jessica
like my feminist guardian angels
and it was a big event very serious full
of meaning and weight and but I feel
that between weight and lightness I
choose I choose lightness and I feel and
I feel I'm dancing the dance of cinema
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]